[Music]
500 million plastic straws are used in
the US every day many of those straws
end up in the ocean and can harm Sea
Life reports predict that by 2050 there
will be more plastic in the ocean than
fish hi I'm Ari and all of those facts
make me feel so frustrated and hopeless
and I've been wanting to do something
about this so today I'm going around my
office and I'm going to be asking all of
my co-workers they'll join me in
refusing single-use plastic straws for a
whole week hello everyone
hi I'm trying to get the whole office to
not use straws for the next seven days
would you be down to do that right heck
yeah hey see a show of hands
amazing I unfortunately don't think I
can at the moment I definitely use
straws way too much
absolutely I never use straws for
anything great okay so this goes a step
further when you're at a restaurant and
you order a drink you ask for it without
a straw okay what don't they give me a
straw Wow will you pledge to do this
challenge with your signature yeah I'm
in night has fallen and by the skin of
my teeth I've managed to collect a
hundred signatures from people around
the office let's see how they do
I'm at a movie but I can't have a straw
in my soda some writing off the Ernest
red firemen do this way
[Music]
[Music]
I despise drinking out of glasses yeah
Nick but we saved the world sorry
now it notices the paper cups I don't
know if I'm really actually helping the
environment by doing this but at least
there's no straw
this one's Ari no one is here I'm going
to be looking in the trashes I see a
strong see another one I am a straw
troll and the trash does not lie I
already failed
I just forgot I would like her red pin
Korea no straw straw I don't know how
many time for actually you spies but I
do and get a lid or a straw you'll need
it and I don't even miss it
[Music]
[Applause]
in a restaurant in Vegas my ass for no
straw
how is she bringing a straw he's yours
for one drink now
this is way harder than it should be and
I need it like people a dog
life's not as fun without straws thank
you so much for coming it's nice to meet
you can you tell me the scoop about
simply strats basically there's five
hundred million plastic straws that end
up in a landfill every single day in the
US alone so we really wanted to offset
that madness so we designed this glass
straw they had it in the 50s we brought
it back into the last 10 to 15 years we
both have been on tour competing
professionally in snowboarding they were
watching all the crazy things happening
with our snowpack and climate change and
our plastic waste channels it's a big
part of the problem
all right so I brought a bunch of straws
I think we should go pass them around
the office see people get stoves yes
yeah Cheers
good morning take your pick
oh yeah these are stronger than normal
gosh these are for silicates like Pyrex
there you go thank you
[Music]
just draw new me you know using a
reusable straws
[Applause]
the end of the challenge how did you do
I did it you did it I didn't use a straw
once really well now I feel like a
failure
I used two straw at least twice these
are the accidentals frost from this week
and for a hundred people
I think this amount is pretty good
considering that most people use about
two straws a day I'm throwing these away
because straws are not recyclable this
week actually turned out to be super
easy it was really hard from now on I
will be 100% straw free I'm definitely
going back to Justin straws from
Starbucks cuz I probably threw this away
about six times beginning of the week I
said that oh I don't use straws you
don't realize how much you straws this
challenge made me more aware of how much
plastic I was using it kind of made me
realize that there are like small things
that you can change in your own life to
better the environment I'm so proud of
everyone
[Music]
if you're watching this and you're still
drinking from straws you just hate
mother earth and it's just that way
I didn't lie truth only